In this lecture we're going to talk
about text access.
In the previous lecture we talk about
natural language content analysis.
We explained that the state of the art
natural language processing techniques
are still not good enough to process a
lot of unrestricted text data in a
robust manner.
As a result, bag of words
representation remains very popular in
applications like search engines.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about some high level strategies.
To help users get access to the text
data.
This is also important step to convert
raw big text data into small relevant
data that are actually needed in a
specific application.
So the main question we will address here is
how can a text information system help
users get access to the relevant
text data we're going to cover two
complementary strategies, push versus
pull.
And then we're going to talk about the
two ways to implement the pull mode:
querying versus browsing.
So first push versus pull.
These are two different ways to connect
users with the right information at the
right time.
The difference is.
Which takes the initiative.
Which party takes the initiative?
In the pull mode, the users would take
the initiative.
To start the information access
process.
And in this case, a user typically
would use a search engine to fulfill
the goal.
For example, the user may type in the
query and then
browse results to
find the relevant information.
So this is usually appropriate for
satisfying a users
Ad hoc information need.
An ad hoc information need is
temporary information need, for
example.
You want to buy a product so you
suddenly have a need to read reviews
about related products.
But after you have collected
information and have purchased your
product.
You generally no longer need such
information, so it's a temporary
information need.
In such a case, it's very hard for a
system will predict your need and
it's more appropriate for the users to
take the initiative, and that's why
search engines are very useful today
because many people have many ad hoc
information needs all the time.
So as we're speaking Google is probably
processing many queries from us and
those are all or mostly all ad hoc
information needs.
So this is a pull mode in contrast, in the
push mode, the system will take the
initiative to push the information to
the user, or to recommend that
information to the user.
So in this case this is usually
supported by a recommender system.
Now this would be appropriate if the
user has a stable information need.
For example, you may have a research
interest in some topic and that
interest tends to stay for awhile, so
it's relatively stable.
Your hobby is another example of a
stable information need.
In such a case, the system can interact
with you and can learn your interest
and then can monitor the information
stream.
If it is, the system has seen any
relevant items to your interest
the system could then take the
initiative to recommend information to
you.
So for example, a news filter or news
recommender system could monitor the
news stream and identify interesting
news to you and simply push the news
articles to you.
This mode of information access maybe
also appropriate when the system has
good knowledge about the users need and
this happens in the search context.
So for example, when you search for
information on the web, a search engine
might infer you might be also
interested in some related information.
And they would recommend the
information to you, so that should
remind you, for example advertisement
placed on search page.
So this is
about the two high level strategies or
two modes of text access.
Now let's look at the pull mode in more
detail.
In the pull mode, we can further
distinguish in two ways to help users
querying versus browsing.
In querying the user will just enter a
query.
Typical keyword query and the search engine
system would return relevant documents
to users.
And this works when the user knows what
exactly are the keywords to be used.
So if you know exactly what you're looking
for, you tend to know the right
keywords, and then querying would work
very well and we do that all the time.
But we also know that sometimes it
doesn't work so well, when you don't know
the right keywords to use in the query
or you want to browse information in
some topic area.
In this case browsing would be more
useful.
So in this case.
In the case of browsing, the users
would simply navigate into the relevant
information by following the paths
supported.
By the structures documents.
So the system would maintain some kind
of structures and then the user could
follow these structures to navigate.
So this really works well when
the user wants to explore the information
space.
Or the user doesn't know what are the
key words to use in the query.
Or simply because the user finds it
inconvenient to type in a query.
So even if the user knows what query to
type in, if the user is using a cell
phone.
To search for information there, it's
still hard to enter the query in such a
case.
Again, browsing tends to be more
convenient.
The relationship between browsing and
the query is best understood
by making an analogy to sight seeing.
Imagine if you are touring the city
now.
If you know the exact address of the attraction
then
taking a taxi, there is perhaps the
fastest way you can go directly to the
site, but if you don't know the exact
address you may need to walk around, or
you can take a taxi to a nearby place
and then walk around.
It turns out that we do exactly the
same in the information space.
If you know exactly what you're looking for,
then you can use the right keywords in
your query to find the information
directly.
That's usually the fastest way to do
find information.
But what if you don't know the exact
keywords to use?
Your query probably won't work, so
you'll land on some related pages, and
then you need to also walk around in
the information space, meaning by
following the links or by browsing.
You can then finally get into the
relevant page.
If you want to learn about the topic again
you will likely do a lot of browsing.
So just like you are looking around in
some area and you want to see some
interesting attractions in a related-
in the same region.
So this is analogy also tells us that
today.
We have very good spot for query but we
don't really have good support for
browsing.
And this is because.
In order to browse effectively, we need
a map to guide us.
Just like you need a map of Chicago to tour
the city of Chicago, you need a topic map
to tour the information space.
So how to construct such a topic map is
in fact a very interesting research
question that likely will bring us more
interesting browsing experience on the
web or in other applications.
So to summarize this lecture we've
talked about the two high level
strategies for text access, push and
pull.
Push tends to be supported by
recommender systems and pull tends to be
supported by a search engine.
Of course in a sophisticated
intelligent information system we
should combine the two.
In the pull mode we can further
distinguish querying and browsing
again, we generally want to combine the
two ways to help users so that you can
support both querying and browsing.
If you want to know more about the
relationship between pull and push.
You can read this article.
This gives excellent discussion of the
relationship between information
filtering and information retrieval.
Here, information filtering is similar
to information recommendation or the
push mode of information access.